avec françois costantini géopolitologue
bonsoir françois constante des
costantini merci et d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france sanction d'un côté
puisse contre sanctions russe de l'autre
annoncé aujourd'hui sur des responsables
européens
quelle est la portée de ces décisions
est ce purement symbolique
bonsoir oui que ce type de décision est
symbolique puisque ça concerne en
général en revient le moins d'une
dizaine de personnes de chaque côté qui
respectivement seraient interdites de
voyager vers le territoire de la russie
et d'autres qui seraient interdites
personnalités russes qui serait interdit
de se rendre dans un pays membre de
l'union européenne on comprend bien
c'est tout
ces sanctions de ce type c'est notamment
souvent qui concerne les chefs d'état de
voir des gels à l'étranger vise plus à
désigner des responsables que en fait à
faire en sorte que des sanctions soient
véritablement opérante d'un côté comme
de l'autre
alors sont elles vraiment efficaces ces
sanctions et d'ailleurs c'est contre
sanction c'est juste un moyen de
pression les uns sans les autres n'ont
ni l'une ni l'autre les sanctions
arrivent à un moment donné les contres
sanctions arrivent de façon host et
rieur pour riposter
donc on peut dire qu en quelque sorte il
s'agit d'un jeu à somme nulle qui a pour
but en quelque sorte de de clarifier les
accueillent les accusations respectifs
mais ce type de sanction est en général
totalement totalement inopérant et n'a
que comme vous l'avez dit qu'une portée
symbolique à des sanctions elle a réussi
des subit depuis ya maintenant 2014 sur
un autre dossier à la crimée est ce
qu'elles ont été efficaces elles ont
produit les résultats escomptés par
l'union européenne
alors là il s'agit il s'agit de sanction
d'une tout autre dimension puisqu'il
s'agit de sanctions économiques et
commerciales notamment sur la russie il
ya eu quand même des sanctions assez
assez marqué puisqu'il ya eu
interruption du partenaire ce partenaire
stratégique entre l'union européenne et
la russie depuis 2014
tenez à stratégiques notamment qui
comprenait la coopération nucléaire et
qui avait en partie permis notamment la
cohésion de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien en 2016 a également il ya eu
également des des contres des contres
sanctions en quelque sorte des mesures
de rétorsion russes qui ont pesé sur les
sur les des embargos agricole et qui ont
coûté très cher notamment aux
agriculteurs européens notamment
français qui je rappelle perdent depuis
les les sanctions les contres sanctions
russe un milliard d'euros par an en
effet la sur le plan économique en effet
les sanctions sont beaucoup plus
opérantes d'un côté comme de l'autre
mais on peut dire que ce sont plutôt les
pays de l'union européenne aujourd'hui
objectivement notamment les agriculteurs
qui ont bâti des sanctions alors les
relations en tout cas s'étaient
réchauffées entre la france et la russie
notamment depuis la rencontre de
vladimir poutine et d'emmanuel macron à
brégançon en 2019
cet épisode est il de nature à saper
durablement en tout cas les efforts de
rapprochement
bah écoutez ce ça ne va pas dans le sens
d'un rapprochement puisqu'on sait que
emmanuel macron en général à une sorte
de police position ambivalente comme il
en a l'habitude
dans le même temps on dirait sur le plan
diplomatique il invite vladimir poutine
pour en quelque sorte contre balancer
son absence du g7 qui est devenu die du
g8 pardon qui est plutôt devenu un
devenu un g7 du fait de l'éviction de la
russie mais d'un autre côté on sait que
par rapport à ce type de de sanction il
se trouve toujours en pointe beaucoup
plus d'ailleurs que que l'allemagne qui
pourtant est directement impliqué dans
dans la sphère navalni donc en effet ce
type en quelque sorte de va et vient
entre l'union européenne d'une part et
et la fédération de russie d'autre part
peut annihiler notamment les tous les
efforts de réchauffement et doit-on
s'attendre un envenimement de la
situation justement entre la russie et
ses pays que vous décrivez alors pour le
pour le moment là faire
les sanctions sont circonscrites à des
personnes mais bon il apparaît comme
exorbitants qu'une affaire comme la
ferme avanies sur laquelle et les
culpabilités sont extrêmement difficiles
à établir
et sur lesquels d'ailleurs on pourrait
peut-être penser que d'ailleurs les l'on
pourrait se retourner d'ailleurs fun sur
fun fameux adage latin ils cessaient de
qui protestent acquis à qui profite le
crime est posé un certain nombre de
questions il faut espère en effet que
cette affaire ne va ni qui est une
affaire partie de l'amour obscures qui
mérite enfin certains de -2
d'investigation et d'explication est en
effet la parole de récentes de monsieur
la vanille ne sombre pas être comme on
dit en en procédure judiciaire une
présomption irréfragable
loin de là donc je pense qu'il faudrait
quand même éviter que cette affaire que
l'on doit au premier tour et décidés à
aider conséquences diplomatiques
politiques et stratégiques
totalement surdimensionné on est dans
une forme de nouvelle affaire un script
halle où il est compliqué de produire
finalement l'épreuve
non c'est un peu différent la sphère
skripal il y avait une affaire
d'espionnage c'est sûr territoire
britannique
là c'est une affaire qui semblerait être
une affaire russo russe donc dont les
implications géostratégiques semblerait
moindre que la sphère skripal quant aux
preuves
ça vous savez il est toujours difficile
de prouver la culpabilité il est certain
que ça cette affaire comme je vous ai
dit et une me paraît être une zone grise
beaucoup plus qu'une zone d'un thé
respectivement de noir et de blanc
merci beaucoup françois constantini
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur air
france